the Joe Rogan experience but you see
people at those mid Hill lit Mill Hill
like it love it
dude let a gang be no one stops you nope
no one stops you from that no one stops
you from taking mushrooms robbery takes
mushrooms for skis that's crazy
maybe does better I'll take mushrooms
after we ski back at the house maybe
take a little bit you'd be better maybe
a tiny bit I'll take a little hit I'll
take I'll get I'll get a little high but
like I can't get I don't want to get
[ __ ] up and feel like I'm not in
control when I play pool
hi I'm better I'm like one ball better
yeah do you think it's in
performance-enhancing drug 100% it is
huh yeah so what do you think about its
way in professional sports
I should sue as well it is for juju what
about like compact like what about
basketball and baseball and so I don't
play basketball but I would imagine it's
similar to pool and then it's a feel
thing like my feeling should be illegal
for professional sports no no I don't
think it should be illegal because it's
like it doesn't make you faster or
stronger I think those are the things
you should make you illegal but it I
think you could be just as focused
without it but for certain people it
enhances your focus it kind of gives you
tunnel vision so that's that but I mean
that's what I'm saying that's the
argument as they say that could be an
advantage I could see that it I could
see you would say that it's an advantage
I feel like it I am better at Jiu Jitsu
when I'm high I really do believe that
like you gotta form better yes I perform
I feel better I feel like I'm more
intuitive I understand positions better
understand where I'm going better you
ever lift weights huh yes and uh you
know it's funny I hate running high I
like a lot of people like to get high
and run love it
no see I get I I can lift weights high
but running high I don't that's not my
favorite yeah Yoga Yoga hi oh my god
okay so that makes more sense it's the
best you feel like every fiber of your
muscles you feel things stretching you
feel where you're pushing too hard like
where things are starting to pop right
you feel it yeah you'll be back to like
the runner's high I get from running
alone I just feel like it's its own kind
of like wonderful little drug right but
lifting because there because I'm such a
a DD guy that lifting is easily
distractible you know you're like
there's so much to do in the gym and so
many you're like what am i doing that I
feel like I'm doing channel
I know yeah I know I like it I like
liftin hi there it is just baked out of
your [ __ ] mind
oh what's the one thing you won't do hi
Oh commentate on the UFC have you done
it before
yes and you were high and if I you felt
like it did you eat [ __ ] no I didn't but
I this is my worry I've never done it
really high my worry is that I wouldn't
want to talk about the fights I'd want
to talk about other things it just
turned into this and we started to talk
warring fight look it's first of all it
would be extremely disrespectful if
while these people who have dedicated
months of their life and years of their
life training and preparing and here
they are in the USC and I barely paid
attention to the far right yeah I'm
subject to not pay attention to them hi
I got that from hi I'm paid attention to
the [ __ ] lighting I'll be like how
weird is it this lighting thing is above
our head it's like a thousand pounds and
never even thought about it
yeah I could fall asleep how many of you
who have died I'd be like how many
people have died from lighting they'd be
like Joe there's a fight going on right
now no I know but this fights come on DC
is like thank you for the lighting tips
Joe we go right back to the fight people
would be angry yeah it emit ly so it's a
dick move that's that like that's that
they're like certain people can be
really baked onstage I can be a little
high but I can't get too high and get on
stage I don't like I just feel like my
performance lacks it's really weird
writing like the other side of it is
enjoyable high like I love creating and
writing and making high but performing
high not my tell you where it's the best
to be super high huh let's stand up on
the spot show Jeremiah walked his show
oh yeah well yes well let's greet it's
all improv it's also a complete
improvisation high as a kite but that's
because it's a it's almost like a
win-win for that thing is like even if
you're not really coming up with like
right [ __ ] that you you're like it's
still in the moment of fun
all that isn't it yeah and when you're
performing while you're doing a [ __ ]
arena no I can't no way I mean we do
we've gotten a little high I can't get I
can't get ripped you know if I'm ripped
I'm not yes I've gotten ripped like the
most ripped I've ever gotten is before
podcast in the early days
podcasting we were talking about this
the other day and that would be in the
middle of talking not knowing what the
[ __ ] I was talking about yeah and I'd be
like wait a minute that's not right what
what am I saying what am I even saying
it was so many podcast that if I look
back on these cringy moments of things
that I said I was like I was so high I
barely knew what I was talking about
right
[Applause]